if you want to hear the disturbing
details of the Bowers gang though
they're too dark for the movie and stick
around to the end of this video one of
the things that makes Stephen King's
fictional town of Derry Maine so
frightening is that it's sewer-dwelling
clown isn't the only monster that the
kids have to deal with the city is also
filled with human monsters and many of
them come from Henry Bowers gang of
bullies my name is Professor C's world
and today on horror history we're gonna
dissect the messed up minds of the young
tyrants of Derry streets so let's take
it back to the beginning with the birth
of Henry Bowers Henry is born in the
year 1946 he is the son of Oscar Bowers
also known as butch
I think Henry's evil tendencies took
foot from an early age as a result of
his parents his father was a mentally
unstable farmer who physically abused
his wife and son so Henry's mother left
the family at a young age
butch eventually started dating a woman
named Rina Davenport since butch was
often at odds with his african-american
neighbor will Hanlin I think Henry
picked up the same racist tendencies and
took things out on will son my every
single member of the losers Club
believed that Henry despised them of the
most but if you were to ask Henry
he'd say Mike is the one that really
draws his ire I mean I don't think he'd
put it so eloquently but you get the
idea
when he was younger Henry killed the
Hamlin's dog mr. chips by feeding him a
poisoned burger and I think the key to
understanding this horrible act is the
fact that Henry was proud as he
presented what he had done to his father
the environment he was raised and really
impacted his actions the kids in Derry
often seemed to agree that when Henry's
father takes things out on him Henry in
turn vents his frustrations into the
other kids of Derry Henry terrorizes the
losers club with his own gang of bullies
when he was six he met Victor Chris who
joins up with Henry mostly out of fear
Victor was the closest thing the Bowers
gang had to intelligence or morality he
seemed more interested in frightening
their victims than hurting them kind of
like how I feel about my viewers and as
the summer progressed it seems like he
becomes more aware of Henry's
deteriorating sanity than anyone else
Henry and Vic could usually be found
with Reginald Huggins who goes by the
moniker belch because
well yeah because of that these three
were the main core of the bowers game
but would sometimes be joined by others
such as Patrick Hawks Tedder who was
maybe more disturbed than Henry himself
although Patrick was quiet and kept to
himself he would partake in the
collection of dead animals he touched
his classmates in inappropriate ways and
killed his baby brother out of jealousy
an event he discovered a sense of
arousal towards violence from other
members of Henry's gang include Peter
Gordon a rich kid who joins Bauer's gang
to boost his reputation
Steve moose Sadler a big strong kid as
his nickname implies who was likely
coerced into joining because he's a bit
mentally handicapped and Henry probably
takes advantage of him and guard Yaeger
Meyer a big slow kid who was described
as being so stupid they don't even
bother sending him to summer school I
definitely need to steal that insight in
the future I love that at the end of the
1958 school year Henry is in danger of
having to do a little summer school
himself again this is something that
scares him because he's supposed to help
his dad on the farm during the summer so
his father will probably beat him if he
has to go to summer school instead he
tries taking his academic frustrations
out on his classmates he goes after a
Richie Tozier
a common target of his because of his
loud mouth one day at school Ritchie
called him banana heels when Henry
slipped on a puddle belch was the one to
notice Ritchie trying to sneak away
after the last bell and they chased him
all the way through town to freeze his
department store
Henry had the intention of seriously
hurting Ritchie and Ritchie was only
able to get away after hiding in the toy
department and sneaking out the
emergency exits
during the last exam of the year Henry
asked Ben Hanscom to let him copy his
work but Ben turns him down causing
Henry to fail the test on the last day
of school Henry gathers Victor and belch
to get his revenge they search dairy and
eventually find Ben going into the
library the three wait for him to come
out and follow him until he's out of
sight
Victor and belched sees him and Henry
pulls out his blade telling Ben he's
gonna carve his name into Ben's gut so
he never forgets to let him copy again
not exactly the smartest thing to do I
mean if any of you are planning on
committing a crime tonight I'd urge you
not to inscribe your real name as
evidence but that's just my advice take
it or leave it Victor didn't think Henry
was actually gonna go through with it
but after carving the letter H
Ben pushes back against him and sends
himself tumbling into the Barrens where
Henry goes chasing after an array Ben
then trips him and kicks him in the
balls
Henry sends Victor and belch after him
but instead they end up finding Bill and
Eddy
who are attempting to build a dam in
this drain when Henry joins back up with
them he does what his father would have
done and takes his frustrations out in
them and their Dam breaking Eddie's nose
and sending him into an asthma attack
Henry Victor and belch would continue
looking for been around town all day
before eventually giving up and getting
on the bus back towards Henry's house as
the summer progresses
Henry becomes crazier and more violent
one Saturday in June Henry and the gang
goats the Aladdin theater for a movie
and on the way there nearly crossed
paths again with Ben Hanscom causing Ben
to hide until they pass by in the mini
series that losers spill concessions on
the bullies but in the book they try to
sneak out a side door after a victor and
Henry look up and see them on the
balcony the Bowers gang trapped them in
an alley with Henry Victor and belch on
one side and two other unnamed thugs
most likely moose and Yeager Meyer on
the other Ben hurls an overflowing
garbage can to knock Henry over then
headbutts Victor belch grabs Beverly
Marcia's hair and tries to slam her into
the wall but she's able to scramble away
and Ritchie uses a garbage can lid to
shield belches oncoming pun before they
all escape I think Henry sanity was
really starting to boil after that it
isn't specifically written what his
reaction is to this fight but King does
describe that Ritchie was expecting
Henry to roll up and try to beat them up
in front of the police station and I
think that goes a long way in conveying
how scary and unbalanced Henry was
becoming he was already developing this
rivalry with the losers but his anger
towards them and his sanity would both
snap on one summer nights
[Applause]
[Music]
before falling asleep Henry heard voices
calling out to him and went outside
where he could hear it's speaking to him
through the moon it's at this point that
Henry is unable to tell his reality from
his nightmares so when it orders him to
kill the losers he gathers up his
friends picks up some fireworks and sets
things into motion on July 3rd 1958 the
Bowers gang are walking around when they
come across Henry's enemy number one
Mike Hamlin they chase him down towards
a creepy abandoned house at 29 niebolt
streets and corner Mike inside the fence
where Henry reveals that he was the one
that killed Mike's dog in retaliation
and Mike begins throwing rocks drawing
blood from Henry's forehead Mike climbs
the fence to get away but Henry reaches
for his foot and Mike kicks down at his
face breaking his nose and sending him
into a mad frenzy pelting Mike with
rocks and firecrackers meanwhile at the
junkyard in the Barrens the six members
of the losers Club are also getting
ready to shoot firecrackers but build n
bro tells everybody to put them away and
collect a stash of rocks because he
feels something is about to happen this
is likely because Billa has a little bit
of shine to him a psychic and
clairvoyant ability most prominently
featured in the shining Henry chases
Mike into the gravel pit in the Barrens
where Mike joins Bill Ben Beverly
Ritchie Stan and Eddie and pelting Henry
with rocks Peter Gordon is the first to
flee probably realizing that Henry had
completely lost it Peter would never
return to Bowers gang after that perhaps
because he was one of the two somewhat
intelligent members and he realized what
he was starting to get himself into and
wanted out Henry hits Beverly with a
pebble causing Ben to go crazy and
tackle him
Henry retaliates by throwing a lit m-80
firecracker at him and then moose comes
in and drags Ben to his knees but the
others pelted his back with rocks Victor
Chris did the most damage to the losers
during this fight perhaps since he was
able to stay calm and find good rocks
which aided his already effective
fastball ability but in the end he ended
up flinching first in a head-to-head
battle with Bill and paid the price for
it with moose and belch covered in blood
bill threatens Henry to try to get him
to leave the Shiksha Bushkin
put you in the hospital as he gets away
Henry screams back at them a farewell
that both he and it's tend to use a lot
when dealing with the losers Club also
worth noting though it may not have been
intentional Henry kind of helps them
overcome it if he hadn't chased Mike
into the Barrens that day the Lucky
seven may have never joined up and their
unity gives them the power to overcome
the manifestations of the monster after
losing the battle that would become
known as the apocalyptic rock fight
Henry was hungry to get his revenge but
it would be another 17 days before their
next encounter I have to imagine he
probably caught up with Peter Gordon
during that time for ditching them
during the rock fights and spent a lot
of time at the parks in town taking his
anger out on whatever kids he could find
between that summer school and working
on the farm for his father I kind of
understand why it wasn't until July 20th
that Henry tracked down one of the
losers Eddie
Casper and they spotted him coming out
of Costello Street markets and Henry
grabbed him before he could slip back
inside henriques max Eddy in the face
and Victor knocks into the ground this
is all happening in broad daylight in
the middle of town which is a testament
to where Henry falls in the sanity
spectrum at this point he pins Eddie
down and stuffs his mouth full of gravel
as revenge for the rock fights
maybe out of fear for hits and maybe
fueled by his own desire for revenge
Henry's attack continues even when an
adult comes and tries to pull him off of
Eddie Henry just pushes the man down and
tells him to go back inside the adults
in Derry have a tendency to turn away
when bad things are happening and the
man whose name is mr. Goudreau backs
down from the 12 year old Henry which I
can only imagine was a horrifying
feeling for Eddie knowing that not even
an adult could save him but it did give
him the moments to try to run at least
until a little kid on a trike gets in
his way and Eddie wipes out Henry
attacks him and breaks his arm and to
his surprise Eddie starts laughing and
Henry actually looks scared I think this
is an important detail because Henry
like it's seems to be affected by their
laughter and I'd theorized that these
two evil characters share this common
weakness because they both need to take
advantage of their victims being afraid
when Eddie laughs it shows that getting
injured isn't so scary and that really
puts Henry's main weapon his brute force
in jeopardy however when they hear the
cop car turn up they come to their
senses and run for it
with Patrick spitting in Eddie's face
before fleeing two days later on July
22nd Bowers victory
bell chuggins and patrick hawk setter
are at the dump using a lighter to
ignite their farts and see who can make
the longest flame laughing as they do so
Henry was supposedly very good at this
because his father's girlfriend made
beans for them once a week I think you
know the song after a day full of well I
was gonna say fun but I think I'll just
say after a day full of that Victor and
belch had to leave so only Patrick and
Henry remain this is where a new side of
Henry Bowers is revealed and it's hard
to blame them for not wanting to put
this stuff in the movie Patrick tells
Henry he wants to try something and
gives him a hand as he also gives
himself a hand when Patrick offers to
put it in his mouth Henry becomes angry
and punches it claiming that he doesn't
go for any of that stuff
Patrick blackmails Henry $1 to keep
quiet about it but Henry has a counter
of his own threatening to expose
Patrick's secret that he's been killing
dogs and cats in town and stashing them
in a refrigerator in the junkyard
soon after Henry left worried that
Patrick would expose his little secrets
little did he know Patrick wouldn't be
exposing anything to anyone as he became
the next victim of it who kills him
using the form of a swarm of flying
leeches one of the last things that
Patrick saw was a figure described as
having a face like running wax trying to
decide what it wanted to be this is
likely because Patrick was so
psychologically messed up that it had
trouble finding the perfect fear for him
we never specifically find out what
happens to the other bullies after that
Peter Gordon hust Adler and guard eager
Meyer are not mentioned again but in
1985 the losers do recall that all of
Henry's friends were killed by it that
summer but it's not clear if Peter moose
and guard were considered to be a part
of that group anymore
maybe Yaeger Meier was just so dumb that
he didn't even bother writing a
conclusion for him I had previously
mentioned that maybe the one member of
the Bowers gang who had some morality
and common sense was Victor Chris and in
early August I think he starts to get
cold feet about being a part of Bowers
gang there's a truck Depot where many of
the kids in town play baseball and Vick
came alone one day to warn the losers
Club that Henry was really losing it I
also think that his lack of loyalty to
Bowers and in turn it was what caused
him to become the next direct victim but
I'll explore that more when we get there
in mid-august Henry noticed some
balloons on his mailbox each of them
with the kids faces on them one by one
the balloons popped and the mailbox
swung down to reveal a package
Robert gray the name used in connection
with the human form of it's the box
contained a new switchblade since Henry
had lost his chasing been in the Barrens
he goes inside were his father's taking
a beer nap and the voice of the moon
tells him to push the switch and kill
butch
Henry's mental state had been
deteriorating all summer the loser's
newest Victor Nuits and maybe even belch
realized it but now Henry's sanity had
snapped after murdering his father the
voice told Henry to get Victor and belch
and go to Kansas Street that afternoon
when he arrived he saw Beverly there and
he heard the voice once again this time
from out of the sewer telling him to
kill her they run after her and Henry
catches her by the hair like the
incident with Eddie at Costello market
Henry defies Authority in favor of
violence when a car horn blasts and a
woman yells out for him to stop
assaulting Bev not backing down he
attacks the woman's car with his knife
and kicks out her taillights causing her
to drive away
Beverly kicks him in the balls and runs
Henry who can barely walk after the nut
shot still insists on catching her which
just goes to show how violence had
become his only priority and perhaps how
he was being overcome by the influence
events the bullies chase her into the
Barrens were they unknowingly stand on
the roof of the loser's underground
Clubhouse Henry knows about the
clubhouse because the voices told him
but doesn't know where it is and he
assumes that it's a tree house or
something
belch makes a terrible joke if they want
a club out clubbin I actually find it
hilarious but only because of how dumb
belches Henry and Victor look around by
one of the sewage pipes where Henry
hears the voice telling where to find
the losers the losers reconvene just
before the remaining bullies show up and
start throwing rocks at this point I
think that Victor and belch are being
controlled or manipulated by its Mike
sees them and thinks that they're
sleepwalking or drugged Ben leads them
to the pumping station with Henry Victor
and belch chasing after them and
throwing rocks it's begun to rain and
it's turning into a thunderstorm by the
time they reach the embankment where
they had previously built the dam where
they're able to load up on ammo to throw
back at the Bowers gang causing Henry
and his friends to peel off to the other
side of the tree line and try to catch
them at the pumping station
Henry arrives as they climb down into
the sewer the last loser to climb in is
Ritchie
Henry slips and falls on a puddle again
causing Ritchie to flick him off and
yell Hey
Nana heels just like that day at school
before disappearing into the sewer the
seven losers stand in a circle at the
bottom of the ladder and since Henry
Victor and belch can only come down one
at a time Henry realizes he descent
about number he throws a huge rock down
to scatter them before coming down but
Richie still bites him on the ankle
before running off into the inflow bite
Victor and belch join Henry and chase
the losers into the sewers after giving
the warning to the losers about Henry's
sanity earlier that month I would come
to the conclusion that it's no longer
saw Victor as a viable ally and
manipulated him into coming down into
the sewers to become its next meal like
Ritchie
we know that Victor has been going to
horror movies at the Aladdin and I'm
guessing it is for this reason that it's
takes the form of the Frankenstein
monster to decapitate him it's unclear
if the plan was to take a belch out as
well but when belch sees this happen he
attacks the monster who easily
overpowers him and tears off half of his
face Henry literally having tunnel
vision leaves his friend to die with
only one focus killing the losers he
never manages to catch up with them
though and after narrowly escaping being
killed by Bill den bro the monster lets
Henry find his way out of the sewer the
rest of Henry summer is not perfectly
spelled out but given the information we
do have I'll try to fill in the blanks
Henry makes it out of the sewers and
decides to return home where police are
waiting for him to take him in for the
murder of his father he goes to trial
where he pleads insanity and they find
him to be a psychopath and place him in
Augusta Asylum many of the people in
town use Henry as a scapegoat for the
murders committed by ID's in 1957 and
1958 and this becomes a widely accepted
theory despite there being no evidence
tying him to these other murders the
fact that the killings stopped as soon
as he was incarcerated and the fact that
he was found to have gone insane was
enough Henry would spend the next 21
years in Augusta before transferring to
juniper Hill asylum in 1976 where he
would sit and count the Night Lights
that burned out inside of his cell until
one fateful day in 1985 when Henry would
encounter an old friend
[Music]
one day after Mike Hamlin made calls to
each of his six childhood friends and
let them know that it had come back
Henry Bowers started to hear voices in
juniper Hill asylum and he thinks
they're coming from the moon he hears
the voices of his old friends Victor and
belch he hears the voices of the losers
Club taunting him and he hears the voice
of Pennywise the dancing clown who tells
him to go back and kill them all
Bowers late awake late one night he had
seen many night lights burn out over the
years they were something that was used
to keep Henry calm and in check so when
his nightlight goes out at that moment
it represents his insanity taking back
over this time he heard the voice come
from under his bed it was his old pal
Victor in the TV mini-series it's belch
of course it's not really Victor belch
it's just another form of it's trying to
get Henry back on its side Victor says
that Henry can hurt the losers
regardless of if they fear him or not
which is technically true and it lets
him out of his cell it uses the form of
Pennywise to scare the guard Coons
then takes the form of a giant Doberman
dog an image that doesn't play
incredibly well in the miniseries to
attack Koontz and let Henry get free
Henry found his steel blade in the storm
drain undoubtedly placed there by EDS
and hitched a ride back into Derry Eddie
would later recognize it as the same
knife that Henry had in the sewers when
they were kids
after reuniting with his old friends at
lunch during the day and at the library
in the evening Mike Hanlon felt he
wasn't alone as he did some writing
after they left
Henry hides out in the glass passageway
between the children's library and the
adults library which is symbolic of the
fact that he never really got to grow up
outside of the mental asylum he still
has a special contempt for the dark
skinned my mic is only armed with a
letter opener but he manages to stab
Henry's forearm with it Henry gets him
back in the thigh but Mike slashes his
ribs
Henry is fat and out of touch but mike
is old and much more frail than he used
to be he has a chance to finish Henry
off but a thought pops into his head
about not wanting to do its dirty work
it takes the form of a young Stan yers
his head and eggs Henry on telling him
to kill Mike but Mike gets the upper
hand and
babs Henry in the stomach Henry flees
the library leaving Mike badly injured
but having taken a lot of damage himself
it's past 2:00 in the morning when Henry
comes upon a sewer grate with a balloon
tied to it but has to hide away in a
bush when he sees a cop car and
ambulance coming by Henry wonders about
if Mike was dead yet and when the cars
passed the voice of its tells him a ride
is coming for him a 1958 Plymouth Fury
pulls out which is significant to Henry
because that was his father's dream car
and it's significant to me because it's
the car from Christine another Stephen
King novel which also has a movie
version I haven't read the book yet but
I've seen the movie and I expected it to
be dumb like no point in going to summer
school dumb but I actually really liked
it but back on topic the driver of the
car and the novel is belch or at least
zombie-like version of belch still
wearing the Yankees cap you are the day
he died I too hoped to be buried in my
Cubs at belch doesn't speak for the
entire ride and most of his nose is gone
Henry clearly not fully understanding
that this is a form of it starts to feel
sorrow for letting belch die and goes on
this whole apology they stopped in front
of the dairy townhouse the hotel that
the losers are all staying at Belcher's
mouth opens to cut off Henry's apology
but instead of his own voice the voice
that Henry recognized from the moon came
out telling him to shut up and get them
I think at this point Henry understands
he retrieves a piece of paper in the
glove compartment with all of the losers
room numbers listed and goes after Eddie
first he knocks on the door and tells
Eddie that he's the bellboy coming with
a message from his wife not really
knowing that Eddie even had a wife this
gets Eddie to open up the door and when
he does he recognizes Henry stabbing the
knife in his direction he shuts the door
on Henry's arm which causes him to drop
the blade but Henry forces his way in
Eddie smashes a bottle and stabs Henry
with it cutting his eye and then his arm
Andrey pushes him back into the table
but ends up falling and impaling himself
on the bottle Eddie's arm is broken
again but Henry is dying and the last
remaining member of the once feared
Bowers gang croaks on a hotel floor
henry's downfall highlights the change
in dynamic that takes place after the
losers Club defeats it in 1958 as kids
they constantly feared Henry and it
would usually take a big group of them
or in some cases all seven of them to
evade his attacks but after the losers
conquered it Henry became the real loser
growing old and fat at the bottom of the
food chain in the asylum while bill Ben
Beverly Ritchie Stan and Eddie went on
to be incredibly successful with Mike
staying back in Derry to Mandalay
so to speak in 1958 Henry and his gang
chased Mike away while in 1985 Mike
chased him out of the library after
putting up a good fight as kids
Eddie's fear of Henry Bowers was only
second to it but as an adult Eddie is
able to take him on one on one
and Henry meets his demise so that's the
entire history of the Bowers gang let me
know in the comments who I should
analyze next on horror history and
remember to subscribe to see Z's world
for new Horrors every week bring that
death belt for notifications and I'll
see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]